[音楽]
dare
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
トランスジャパンアルプスレースというのをなんなんだっ
みなさんどんな出すっていうのかなどんなことかちょっとし
聞いたことあるよっていう人ちょっといいましたねー
おおありがとうございます予想にも反してあのたくさん入ってくれて嬉しいことなん
ですけども
ちょっとですね今日本当は走る格好でこうと思ったんですけどまさか外が寒いので
このような格好で来させてもらってですねこれあのレースのときに使う
リックなんですけどもちょっとですね409とか走るレースやってきて
こういうのこういう緊張する場でですねつよってないと僕もは安心しないものですから
ちょっとせを果たしてもあって
やらせてもらいますで
話なんですけども415機を10分ぐらいで話すのがですね
ちょっと何を話していいのかわかんなかったのでもう少しそれをまとめてですねええ
自分がそのレースのなかで感じてきたこととまぁこんなことが自分にとって走る
一つのやる気につながったということを今日話したいと思います
マザーのトランスジャパンアルプスレースというのは富山県の魚津市というところが
あるんですけどそこ
日本海に接してるんですね海に接していて
村日本海の海を
海を触ってですね日本アルプスと言われるあの北アルプスあ
剱岳とかやり方気があるようなんで中央アルプス
そして南アルプスって
さらにそこから南下して静岡市の大浜海岸の太平洋の海を去って1週間以内にゴール
するというえ
変わったですね誰がそんなことやるんだったような
山岳レースがありますでそのレースはまあ制限時間は1週間以内にゴールすることあと
は自分の歩きと走り
のみでやってくる誰からのサポートも受けてはいけませんよと言う s ですね
あの途中で
これ食べなんとかこれもってキラーとかあと車に乗ったりとか自転車ちょっと乗ったら
いいじゃんとかそういうあのは気にされているレースですね
まあ限界自分がどこまでやれるか自分の限界をチャレンジするようなそういった
ベストしてあのやっていますで
あとはるーるー厳しいルールがいろいろありまして参加するにもですね
書類選考があったり予選会があったりして
現在は30名しか得られないような大会となって厳しい大会となっています
あの山が今泊まってはいけないというようなレスです
そういったレースをやってくるんですけどもスタートは夜中の霊視
何も普通の人たら普通寝る時間にスタートおきます
で御寿司その日本海をスタートしてですね
一人で闇夜の中ヘッドライトの明かりだけはですね
頼りに
進んでいくわけですして最初の山剣だ減の振り
とりかかるんですけどもだんだん日が a
上がってきてですね対応が上がってきて朝の6時ぐらいですかね
上がってくると a 3用山のですね
影というか三陽を照らし出していきますそれが朝やけだったりとか
麗江赤く染まってきたりするそういう景色を見ながらうわーもう感動しながらですね
いい景色だなぁと思いながら登って着るとまぁ山頂ではこう対応が
a もう眩しいくらいな明かりを行
平地ではですね見られないようなまぶした
まあその対応の強さを感じながらへ
行ってきますね
山頂に着くとですねさらに欄干にはですねええ
3000m の山々が連なってるわけなんですね
天気がいいとやっぱり200キロぐらい先
まあ北アルプスの山頂に登った時南アルプスの山頂が見えるぐらいですね
見渡せるような景色が広がるんですけどもであんなとこまで行くのかっていう風に
やっぱり思う思いますねでで
ん
僕はもうこの大会に4回チャレンジしてます
毎回ですねゴールするために
あそこはこうしておけばよかった
あんときに頑張っておけばよかったなっておけばよかったっていう風な感じですね
公開や続いてやってきた結果の4回も行ってしまったという音なかったことを4回も
行ってしまったやっぱ
感じなんですけどもまぁそうやって遠くを見えたときに自分の足というか人間のあ c
値からってすごいなっていうのを感じ
ながらやってきました
その中ではいろんな経験レースの中ではですね色んな経験はしてくるんですけども
やっぱりあの眠気があったりとか
腹あの寝ずにやってくる
ネズミというかですね1日だいたい2時間くらいしか寝ないんですそれもね時間
ずーっと寝れるわけじゃなくて
10分とか20分そしたらまた起きて進むというようなレース展開は僕はしてくるわけ
なんですけれども
その中でやっぱりねぇ向けだとかあとは食べ物空間ですねあとは
さんがさだったりとかまあとは
体の痛みですね400キロも走ってくるとどうしても筋肉が損傷してきたり
もう節々関節そういったものはすごく痛くなってきます
でそんな中進んできてあとは真っ暗闇の一人山の中を歩いていると
ラッキーですかねぇ
五感が研ぎ澄まされてくるような感覚になるんですね
だんだんこう体も当然痩せてきます
で聞こえないようなものというかこう
心臓ノートがすごく頭の中で独力したりとかあと葉っぱの音とか風の音とかそういった
ものをすごく聞こえるようになってくるし
はたまたです
あの
聞こえない音っていうんですかね幻聴っていうやつですね
誰かこんな山の30近くん山の中にいるはずのないような人の声
故障個所が書5章箇所って聞こえるんですね
幻聴が聞こえたりとかあとは幻覚を見ますね
切り株が人の母に見えたりとか
あとはまあ人の顔に見えでゲート何も怖くないんですけども
こうよってこいよと来いって言う招きの幻覚がありますそれはちょっと怖いですいない
んだけどもそこに行ってみると崖だったとかそういったものもあったり中にはですね
このレースに参加している30名の中のうちには中には石ころが
a
お財布に見えちゃうと言いました
いっぱい肯定しをここに置いてですね
西広たっていうような人もいますし
葉っぱがみんなの応援するてだったりとかしてもらってやっていくようなまぁそんな
ような
あった経験も
していきますまあだからこのたぶんこんなことをやって出題車買ってる人なんですけど
ね
あーまあそれ4やる僕はさらに一部は変わってるなぁと思うんですけど
まあそういった経験をしながらやってきて
まあ辛い子じゃあ何でそんなことやるんだろうっていうのを今日話できればいいんです
けどたぶん僕も聞いている方だったらなんでそんな辛いことやってまいりそういうこと
すんのっていうのは一番聞きたいことだと思うんですけど
それキュッキュッとまた長くなっちゃうので今日はちょっとそこはまたの機会という
ことで開くして
で辛いことを
やっぱりそういう経験をしてくる中で今度はまた辛いこともあるんですねえ辛いことの
一番
辛かったっていうのはまあ
後ろの選手抜かれることですベースという名前ついていてどうしても僕としては自然の
中で自分への挑戦だと言っているところが多いんですけどもやっぱり人には負けたく
ない
っていうところでどんどん僕も抜かれたことがあるんですね
簡単に後ろ側に置いてる人がいたりとか都留市
そういう後は
寒さですね
3000m の上ではやっぱり10度位以下になってしまいです夏場でも
8月の仲間でも10度以下になってしまう頭た
山からおいてきてですねロードの股間を東道路の区間もあるんです
そういったところでは37度とか38度の100月地獄がですね
待ちかまえていますそういったものを感じたりあとは台風は
4回のうちですね台風が来たのが3回くらいきていてもうよくテレビでアナウンサーが
台風が来ると合算してひっくり返っちゃった方がひっくり返っちゃったなんて言うなん
ですけどもあんなもんじゃないんですね
右側抱いた40m くらいと言われていて逃げ場がないんですね
日が生えてないんです山の山頂はそこでじゃあどうやって自分は
これを回避するのか
あとは終わってやり過ごすのかそんなときちょっと自分も怖い目をしたりして
でもまあそういう辛い場面をですね一つ一つずつ乗り越えてくることが自信につながる
すごくそれがやれたってことが自信につながってこれからのなんていうんですかね
山の経験とか知識にもつながってくるわけです
でまぁそんな中で一つ自分が今でもまあ思い残る出来事がありましてそれはあの自分の
中で三伏峠事件って言うんですけども
あの2000南アルプスの山行きの中に2500メートルぐらいの位置にですね
強硬なんですけどもこの三伏峠小屋というところがあります
そこに行くには静岡からですと車で5時間
そして登山口から登って7時間ぐらいかかりますそれはですね
静岡の仲間が応援に来てくれたんですねそれは第2回2012年の大会の時だったん
ですけども
そのときに僕はもヘトヘトでですね
限界に来てたんですそれは
あの周りからも優勝とか新記録だしてそれに回目の大会だったので連覇を狙って
とか俺自分の中でも狙うぞ今年も優勝するぞとかという気持ちでいたんです
でアシュリーととか
多分同じ考えなのかもしれないんですけども応援してくれる人たちに何が恩返しが
できるかって考えたときにやっぱりそういう
記録とか結果を出して喜ばせることが僕たち天使があの恩返しできることじゃないのか
なって僕は思ったのでそう思って走り続けてきたんですけどその三伏峠の近くでですね
もう限界に達しました精神的にも肉体的な
して仲間が待ち続けてくるっ
てくれていたんですねえっ
それ僕がねそこにその時間にくるっていうのは全然わからないです
今のように gps があるような時代ではなかったのでいつ来るかいつ来るかと思っ
てずっと待っててくれた
寒い中待ってくれてそしてその人たちに会ったときにちょっと&
の顔が出たんですねホッとしたんですけどもう限界ですって言ったんですね
中に盲目は
今年止めますんでいたしますったら称賛
僕たちはね菖蒲さんが元気で笑顔でね静岡に帰ってきてくれればいいんだってことを
言ってくれたんです
優勝しろとか新記録を出すなんてそんなことこれぽっちも持ってないよってことを言っ
てくれたんです
そこで肩の荷がホッとしてですね本当にそこで
more そうなんだと思って行
考えている僕の思っていることと応援してくれる人の思ってることがちょっとズレてて
ですね
その一言に
安心してまた一から走り出すことができました
でいろんなこの寒さとか暑さとかそういう精神的なところとかも
いろいろ経験してきた中で僕思ったんです
やっぱりこのレースこういう過酷なレースというか変わったレースなんですけどそう
いったことはすべてを
受け止める自然の脅威とか自然の猛威っていうんですかね
そういう
多いとか脅威とかそういったものも受け入れる寒さも厚さも受け入れる
そして応援してくれる人たちの気持ちも全部受け入れなければこのレースはゴールでき
ないじゃないかととその受け入れた時に
まあ価値というか自分に勝てるんじゃないかなっていうのをこのレースで感じてきまし
た
今年あの2010
6年4回目の挑戦してですねえ
結果はあの浴客と504日と23時間52分ということですね
ちょうど山の日です今年イチから山の日ができたんですけれども
その日に帰ってくることができましたもうスタートしてからゴールまですね
辛いことが何もありませんでしたすべてが楽しかったんです
それは嫌
やっぱり自然も気持ちも全部受け入れられた方からだと僕は思っています
そしてなによりも
楽しかった楽しむことがやっぱり次へつながる一歩だと僕は感じましたのでぜひ皆さん
も楽しいなと思うことですね
に一歩踏み出してこれから
挑戦していろんなことにチャレンジしていってもらえたらなと思っていますどうも
ありがとうございました
[拍手]